alors c'est avec une grande satisfaction
que nous accueillons la décision qui
vient d'être rendue
mais en mon nom et au nom de tous les
avocats du collectif puisque nous sommes
7 nous avons une pensée émue pour les
usagers de 10,6 situé sur la commune du
lamentin et peut être ailleurs qui sont
injustement privés d'eau depuis certains
certains depuis plus de 20 jours
cela constitue manifestement un trouble
dans des conditions d'existence qui est
intolérable surtout en cette période de
pandémie
notre pensée va vers eux et nous leur
disons qu'aujourd'hui c'est un premier
pas et que la justice les attentes les a
entendus la justice les a entendus parce
qu dc est condamné à rétablir
immédiatement l'alimentation en eau
potable au sein de ces habitations au dc
est condamné à faire cesser le trouble
manifestement illicite qui est constitué
par les coupures d'eau prolongée et
récurrentes dont ils sont victimes au dc
est condamné à indemniser par provision
le préjudice subi et les usagers sont
autorisés tant que le problème n'est pas
réglé à consigner le paiement de leurs
factures entre les mains du bâtonnier
voilà ce que nous pouvons dire à brûle
pourpoint un show concernant cette
décision qui nous ravit et qui va ravir
les usagers situé sur la commune du
lamentin